Могила в оренду – і не більше 25 років – такі закони у Німеччині
Скільки коштує похорон у ФРН
Як стати після смерті деревом
Друзі, всім привіт! Ніщо не є вічним у цьому світі.
Такі думки виникають, коли прогулюєшся цим цвинтарем у Бонні.
Приблизно такий самий вигляд мають тисячі інших кладовищ у ФРН.
Рівні, охайні ряди могил, доріжки між ними, жодних огорож і столів.
Порядок і простір. Пропоную у цій серії дізнатися про культуру
поховання у Німеччині і закони, які її регулюють.
Квіти на похорон в Німеччині приносять не у парній кількості.
Натомість є традиція замовляти у флористів спеціальні жалобні букети та вінки.
Bestattungsgesetz - Закон про поховання - визначає терміни і правила
цього процесу. Цей закон – як і у деяких інших сферах у Німеччині -
у кожній із 16-ти федеральних земель різний. Але відмінності – незначні.
У Бонні близькі покійного мають організувати похорон протягом максимум 10 днів -
такий порядок у землі Північний Рейн Вестфалія. Їду до сусідньої землі
Рейнланд-Пфальц, аби дізнатися про місцеві закони і поховальні традиції.
Заїжджаю до міста Трір - тут у мене домовлена зустріч
із власником бюро ритуальних послуг.
Ви лише подивіться, який позитивний заєць, одразу і не здогадаєшся,
що це похоронне бюро. Це сімейний бізнес родини Гаас.
Розпитаємо професіоналів про німецьку культуру поховань.
Вітаю! Ласкаво просимо до Похоронного бюро Гаас.
Це родинний бізнес, який існує у Трірі з 1996 року.
Я його власник - Матіас Гаас.
На сайті бюро вся родина Гаас сяє посмішками і на логотипі красуються зайці.
Ніяких асоціацій з трауром. 34-річний Матіас вже під час знайомства пояснив,
що прізвище Гаас співзвучне із словом Газе - заєць німецькою,
тож і вирішили зробити вухастих символом підприємства.
Власник знайомить з асортиментом і цінами.
Ось тут у нас зовсім проста труна із сосни.
Її вартість - тисяча дев’яносто євро.
Є і більш високоякісні труни з дикої осики,  це цільне дерево.
Ціна за таку труну сягає двох - двох з половиною тисяч євро.
За законом труна потрібна і під час кремації,
не можна спалювати тіло просто у савані.
Ось така сталева урна для праху - найпростіша. Є керамічні урни,
є ручна гончарна робота. А ось ця урна зі штучного еко-матеріалу,
який розкладається з часом. Це справжній тренд на сьогодні.
На такі урни - найбільший попит.
Ціна на урни для кремації коливається від 150 до 300 євро.
Кремація стає дедалі популярнішою альтернативою традиційному похованню,
зокрема і тому, що це дешевше. Станом на 2021 рік середня вартість
традиційного поховання у ФРН сягає 13 тисяч євро.
А витрати на кремацію – у середньому 9 тисяч.
Матіас пропонує розповісти про різновиди поховань, тож вирушаємо до Центрального цвинтаря.
Трір має історію у понад дві тисячі років.
Ми  прогулюємося повз саркофаги часів Римської імперії.
Матіас каже, що послуги його бюро - це юридичне оформлення усіх
документів після смерті, пошук місця на цвинтарі,
організація церемонії - коштують не більше двох з половиною тисяч євро.
Дедалі більше людей у Німеччині ще за життя укладають договір з такими бюро,
повністю розписують сценарій свого похорону і поступово виплачують гроші,
аби, коли прийде їхній час, ці витрати не  лягали на плечі рідних.
Моєму здивуванню не було меж, коли я почув,
що місце під могилу орендується на обмежений час.
Є встановлений законом у кожній федеральній землі базовий час,
на який орендується могила. У землі Рейнланд-Пфальц це 15 років.
Це визначений період часу, протягом якого тіло у труні залишається
саме на цьому місці. У Трірі на цвинтарях діють приписи
про можливість проплати оренди місця на 20 і максимум 25 років.
Коли термін спливає і оренда місця не проплачується далі, ще на 25 років уперед,
у Трірі це коштує 2,5 тисячі євро, прибирають могильний камінь,
розкопують могилу, проводять анонімне перепоховання рештків на території цвинтаря
або у боковому заглибленні у цій же ж могилі.  І місце готове для нового поховання.
Є могили, де місця поруч можна докупати, а є такі, де це неможливо.
Отут ми бачимо типовий приклад, як виглядає і який розмір має
сучасне традиційне поховання на дві могили.
Як і у багатьох інших царинах в Німеччині, на цвинтарях існують
десятки можливих варіантів поховань. Я прошу Маттіаса показати,
де ховають після кремації і який зараз найтрендовіший тип кремаційних поховань.
Ось навколо цього дерева ховають урни з прахом.
І поки всі місця не зайняті, над ними стоять хрести.
Коли все заповниться, це місце перетворять на галявину.
Ось подивіться на це дерево - так це виглядатиме.
А трохи далі ліворуч ставиться надгробний камінь,
де є всі імена і дати життя похованих тут людей.
Загалом у ФРН кремують 60 відсотків померлих.
Причому на півночі Німеччини кремують 90 відсотків померлих,
а на півдні, у Баварії - лише 10 відсотків.
У 2020-му році у Німеччині пішли з життя 986 тисяч людей,
десять років тому ця цифра сягала 859 тисяч.
Тож для тих, хто надає ритуальні послуги, роботи побільшало.
При цьому з'явилась тенденція щодо скорочення звернень для проведення церемоній
до церковнослужителів. За останні 20 років кількість церемоній поховань,
проведених церквою, скоротилася на 88 тисяч - з шестиста до 512 тисяч церемоній.
Німці стають більш креативними у своїх останніх побажаннях.
І поступово відходять від усталених традицій.
Ось ця білочка на рекламному буклеті символізує новий тип поховань - ліси упокоєння.
Friedwald - ліс спокою, тут немає пам’ятників та вінків.
Лише ось такі маленькі таблички на деревах.
Такі поховальні ліси почали з’являтися  в Німеччині 20 років тому.
Показати цей ліс і своє майбутнє дерево погодився
герой серії відеоблогу "Відкривай Німеччину" про пенсіонерів -
вчитель історії мистецтва Аксель Рюдіґер Вестфаль.
Це є справжній ліс, однак всі дерева у ньому пронумеровані.
І завдяки цьому можна орієнтуватися у ньому під час пошуку могили.
Мій брат лежить десь тут, а я лежатиму в цій частині.
Я не пам’ятаю номер мого дерева і ніде його не записав.
Ну що ж, вирушаємо на пошуки дерева пана Вестфаля.
На доріжках стоять таблички з назвами лісових вулиць для ще кращого орієнтування.
У лісі упокоєння ховають лише прах в еко-урнах,
які за два роки розкладаються повністю. Концепція цього цвинтаря у тому,
що людина вийшла з природи і у природу піде.
Фактично прах стає добривом для дерева.
Ось тут навколо дерева - близько десяти могил.
На табличці прізвища і імена  десятьох померлих -
з датами народження і смерті. А це номер поховання.
Номер дерева і прізвища померлих прив’язані до GPS-координат
і вони внесені власниками лісу до електронної бази.
Місце тут купується на термін від 15 до 99 років. І власники бізнесу обіцяють,
що якщо дерево впаде або ландшафт зміниться -
координати поховання дозволять все  відновити.
Надешевше місце, без права вибору, лісник знайде клієнту за 490 євро.
За 7 тисяч євро можна придбати ціле дерево з 20-ма місцями
для урн навколо нього. Зустрічаємо групу пенсіонерів, які прийшли подивитися на дерево,
яке обрав один з них. Всі жартують і сміються
і з легкістю переходять на серйозні теми.
Мені - 86. І я вирішив, тут у лісі, знайти
свій останній прихисток. Так склалося, що наша культура поховання вже  змінилася.
Я лісник за професією і я хотів би бути похованим тут на природі.
Коли мене згадуватимуть пізніше і відвідуватимуть мій останній притулок,
я би хотів щоб люди забирали з собою звідси трохи цієї атмосфери.
А ось таке на вигляд місце для прощальних церемоній просто неба.
Лавки для рідних і друзів. Вівтар і підставка для урни з прахом, зроблені з колод.
Свіже місце поховання прикрашають зеленими гілками лише перші кілька днів.
Мох, листя, трава та сніг надалі прикрашатимуть могилу,
свічки та будь-які інші атрибути цвинтаря тут заборонені -
йдеться у правилах користування. Після двох годин блукань лісом
наш герой знайшов таки своє дерево.
Я шукаю товсте дерево, ага, це може бути ось це,
давай подивимося на табличку. Так, це воно!
Номер три тисячі сто сімдесят один. Напис: Не існує початку,
не існує кінця і ми посередині. А ось і моє місце поховання, дата народження
і відсутня дата смерті. Якесь своєрідне відчуття.
Ти усвідомлюєш, що ти тут лежатимеш і що ти є смертним.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що ще б ви хотіли дізнатися про німців
та їхню країну і побачите це в наступній серії! Нехай щастить!